conservatoire
[Musique]
elle a dit ce qu'elle avait besoin de dire la dernière
fois et tout le monde regarde maintenant euh
c'est
la plus grande différence entre euh aujourd'hui et
avant que vous ne sachiez que nous
tout le monde sait ce qui se passe il y a
un œil plus attentif sur tout
et euh vous savez que nous aurons des nouvelles de
que se passe-t-il à l'intérieur au moins
pour que nous entendions bien les nouvelles la dernière fois que nous
avons été justifiés la dernière fois que nous avions le
cœur brisé parce que toutes nos
pires craintes ont été confirmées
euh cela devrait en fait être résilié cela
fait trois semaines
je ne sais pas pourquoi c'est encore  continue
je pense que
corrompu toute la cour des successions
est
corrompue  ils les
incarcèrent, ils n'ont pas de voix, puis ils les
tuent, donc c'est ce que britney
représente l'espoir
pour nous tous et j'espère que cela mettra
en lumière d'autres tutelles
pour aimer les abus envers les personnes âgées et tout ça, tu
sais t  c'est une voix parmi des
milliers à ce stade, alors peut-être que cela
fera changer les lois pour tout le monde
euh en Amérique et peut-être même dans le
monde entier
vous